ce document confirme ce que beaucoup
redoutaient le renversement de l'arrêt
roe contre wade chaque état serait
dorénavant libres d'interdire le droit à
l'avortement les réactions ne se sont
pas fait attendre
bernard ils ne vont pas s'en sortir
comme ça dit elle on est plus nombreux
qu'eux et on va se battre toute la
journée les manifestants ont défilé
devant la cour suprême pour les deux
amériques s'affrontent
le document de 98 pages a mis le feu aux
poudres et ramènerait les états unis 50
ans en arrière le très conservateur juge
samuel alito écrit raw était erroné de
façon flagrante depuis l'origine son
raisonnement était incroyablement faible
et la décision a eu des conséquences
très dommageables
les neuf juges de la cour suprême devait
trancher sur la question à la fin du
mois de juin ou début juillet
la fuite publiée par le site politico a
eu l'effet d'une bombe la grande
question qui en est l'auteur une enquête
est en cours pour abus de ce week jeudi
parce que quel que soit le responsable
dit il il doit être poursuivi et elle
est en prison pendant longtemps car il a
ébranlé l'indépendance même de la cour
suprême le document est authentique
confirme le chef de la cour suprême mais
pas final
seuls
cela touche toutes les décisions liées à
la vie privée qui vous mariez dit-il en
flore et 10 peuvent passer une loi
interdisant le mariage gay
je suis en colère lance la sénatrice
démocrate elizabeth warren la cour
suprême est en train d'imposer ses
points de vue extrémistes et ce sont les
femmes pauvres qui vont payer le prix
ajoute elle pour beaucoup il ya une
profonde guerre de culture aux états
unis
les droits de 100 millions de femmes
sont en jeu dit il et les américains
doivent se faire entendre lors des
élections de mi mandat en novembre
avec 7,8 la cour suprême vient de perdre
un peu de son lustre c'est the bodyguard
qui sera du canada à washington
[Musique]